we've thought about how you can talk
about optic flow with little changes in
space and little changes in time that
means derivatives and so things like
cibele which we can calculate across the
image so there's something called the
optic flow equation which basically
combines these derivatives in the image
these gradients and also in that
equation than are these two things that
we want to get out this U and this B so
these are our optic flow vector for each
pixel which ways things going in order
to do that though we have to make some
more assumptions because there's two
unknowns and we have one equation so
this is where people come up with a load
of different ideas for how to frame the
problem so that you can get at those U
and V values so one method that solves
for optic flow and gives you these
little what are called cuivre plots
where for each pixel here you've got
this U and V vector so you can plot
these across a whole image and if you
look in the video there's on screen now
you can see all these plotted and
showing things moving around one of the
methods for calculating this stuff
originated in the 80s so I think it was
1981 by a couple of people called horn
and shunk so if you look up optic flow
this will be the sort of one of the
first techniques that's mentioned again
so bear in mind that in in the 80s it
was a challenge just to get any kind of
video onto a computer at all and yeah
you know you're talking about working
with TV standards like pal or NTSC
rather than things like VGA which came
hold on sort of nearer nearer the 90s so
these are going to be originally quite
low resolution images maybe 320 by 240
about 4k images here nowadays yeah
you've got a lot more calculations to do
so the assumption that Horne shunk make
in order to get out these U and V
components of optic flow is that they
look in the local neighborhood so as
well as just considering an individual
pixel so we haven't got enough
information there to figure out optic
flow is what they do is they say
actually
let's look at the neighboring pixels
here and we're going to basically put in
a constraint into our silver that says R
U and V here should be quite similar to
an average use and an average V in the
local neighborhood what we're going to
assume is that this motion isn't going
to radically change between pixels if
we're on a surface the motion change is
going to be small unless you're at an
edge of course so would break another
constraint there but most of the time
you know if this table is moving around
all the pixels are going to be moving in
roughly in the same direction so we have
this smoothness constraint that we build
in and horn chunk is a global approach
so for every single pixel in the image
it will try and optimize for working out
ru and being the local pixel and pairing
that to the the average U and V in there
in the local area so it's this iterative
scheme so it's pretty slow where it goes
through and tries to kind of globally
find the best U and V it's a fairly
image it looks to me like you've got to
work out if something that's the same is
has now moved into a different area is
that what you kind of like yeah you know
is it is that but remember that the
motion that we're talking about is
really tiny so we're not talking about
something that's moved forward ten
pixels that will break optic flow though
we can talk about how you can fix that
at the end because there's one quite
neat trick you can do if something's
moved really fast we're talking about
tiny movements so almost kind of sub
pixel pixel level movements here so it's
picking up changes in brightness
patterns spatially but also over time as
well and all the equations do is figure
out a way to get these estimates of of
where's that little change in brightness
has gone across the whole image in the
case of Hong jeong-ho chunks the global
method is trying to do everything across
the whole image so there's a load of
other approaches that will calculate
this another really common one is called
the lucas-kanade a approach to solving
it and rather than trying to say look
let's
optimize this thing globally across the
whole image they look at a little patch
so they take a patch of pixels so again
this looks a bit like a kernel I guess
so it's normally sort of five by five
and you see you're considering the pixel
in the middle but what the lucas-kanade
a approach says is let's assume that U
and V is going to be the same in all of
these pixels in this region and that
gives us 25 equations
which is over determined so you can use
least squares to figure out the best fit
essentially for u and V there and of
course all these things are making a
huge load of assumptions that which I've
already hinted we have to break quite a
lot so if you've got an edge here for
example that maybe this object is moving
that way and this object is moving that
way you're going to have problems
figuring out a U and V there so some
constraints my building things that try
and separate our edges because it tends
to break this stuff another quite
interesting problem that you get with
some of these methods is something
called the aperture problem so this is
where we're trying to figure out motion
so it's called the aperture problem
because we've only got a little window
that we can see motion happening in so
the question is which ways that line
moving so if we had to put optic flow
vectors on this line where would you say
it was going well I mean the obvious
thing to say is it's going down but it
could of course be a diagonal line
moving right it's good answer because it
can be lots of things if we take away
that window this is the motion that
we're actually getting so the lines just
moving across the image from left to
right but it looks there that it's kind
of either going diagonally down right or
down kind of depends on how you
interpret it I guess this is called the
aperture problem or the barbershop pole
illusion because it's got stripes moving
up and down and the idea being that
there's not enough information here to
to accurately figure out how that that
feature is moving it's very easy here
because we can see the corners so
corners are a bit special and they allow
us to sort of refine our estimates of
motion so sometimes if we're only
looking in a
in a small window like here we can get
ambiguous motion happening that we can't
determine because of things like the
aperture problems that's another sort of
issue with these these methods the only
other thing that I wanted to mention
here is that so horn chunk is global we
talked about it kind of finding the best
set of you and Vees across the image
this approach here is local so we only
care about making it work on a five by
five patch of pixels essentially but
they've got advantages and disadvantages
so one of the advantages of the global
approach is if we've got an object here
that's moving at the edges you know
there's enough brightness changes that
we can pick up a movement happening but
there's a question about if this is just
a sort of orange or white or whatever
shape what's happening in the middle of
it it's like the spinning ball we can't
tell so the nice thing about a global
approach is it will kind of fill in from
the information it knows it will fill in
the edges throughout the shape okay the
problem with the local approach is is if
you've just got a patch here yeah you
can kind of figure out a u and V in this
location but if your patch is in the
middle of one of these texture list
shapes it's kind of an undetermined
solution so you might get some sort of
noisy approaches so it swings and
roundabouts as with other than all of
this stuff as to whether you use a
global approach or a local approach and
they've got trade-offs and speed and
things like that it's just two examples
there's loads of different ways of
calculating optic flow people are doing
it with deep learning now as well of
course so lots of different ways of
doing and it's still even though it's
been around since the 80s it's it's a
very useful technique still as a way of
pre-processing things perhaps as a
precursor for segmentation so if this
shape here and the background are a very
similar color or texture but this shapes
moving and the backgrounds not moving
you've not got any Flav actors on the
background you can use the optical flow
field as a way of segmenting what's
going on okay so we said that the motion
has to be really small for any
this to work so you need a really small
time between frames again another
assumption that's going to get broken
all the time is that stuff moves more
than a few pixels so if you've got an
image that looks like this and you've
got something here and in the next frame
it moves down here it flows not gonna
like that and it's gonna break so you're
not gonna get a good value out for that
there's a trick called building an image
pyramid which certainly the lucas-kanade
a approach uses so you might read about
this approach using a pyramid scheme and
all that means it's actually pretty
simple
you make your image lower resolution to
start with so perhaps if I switch to
live in color imagine if instead of
being a four by four pixel image this is
a 2x2 pixel image and then whatever
shape we've got here yeah okay so it a
ver ajiz out a bit because we're sort of
blurring it with our surrounding ones
but now they've become neighboring
pixels and we've essentially shrunk the
space over the motion that's happening
so you end up with this pyramid sort of
system where you have low resolution
lower down and then you kind of move up
to higher and higher resolutions
that's a terrible image do you think you
have to average out and say okay that
one picks the same for 20 pixels or
exactly so you use this as a way to kind
of bootstrap the rest of it so you
calculate your motion here so you get
your motion vectors that might look like
this on the low resolution one and
essentially you populate the next level
up with estimates of the motion from
these so you know whatever was here gets
filled into these four pixels and then
you do the scheme again but because
you've got a starting point this time it
will help you sort of overcome some of
those bigger motions is this being used
these days you mentioned deep learning
what what sort of things is it used for
at the moment yes used today so I
mentioned it can be used for image
stabilization so you can stabilize an
image by looking at how the pixels are
moving around you don't have to
calculate it across the whole image if
you want to do it really quickly you
could just kind of sample bits of it but
you want to get an idea of is the camera
moving around
world in some way and then you can sort
of in software correct for that another
use is frame interpolation so if you've
got 25 frames per second video and you
want to turn it into kind of fake
slow-mo if you just stretch out your
frames it will go all kind of jaggedy
right so you get a frame and then the
next frame and because you've filmed it
at normal speed and you're slowing it
down it doesn't look very nice so if you
know how things are moving across the
frame you can add in sort of fake extra
frames so if this is your first frame
and your second frame you can add in
additional frames in the middle which
you can use optic flow to kind of figure
out how brightness is moving around at
that point and if you know how the sort
of local patterns are moving about you
can put them in a sensible place in
those interpolated frames so rather than
just pure sort of smoothing or
interpolation between them it's kind of
a bit more sensible than that a bit
cleverer and you can move surfaces sort
of where they should be so there's some
quite sort of neat plugins and tricks
coming around doing that kind of stuff
and one way you can do that is using
optical play if you're trying to follow
something moving very fast in an image
you know a thing rather than just
talking about movement at the pixel
level that's going to be where you're
you're looking at object tracking which
perhaps we can do a video on in the
future for a number of reasons if you've
got a wobbly shaky camera you can use it
for image stabilisation I wasn't
insinuating anything yeah so you can use
optic floaters see what kind of global
motors bokeh blur I don't know how to
pronounce that way okay is right okay my
vocab okay yeah